there are certain rules that one must
abide by in order to successfully
survive a horror movie
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
corne sir same stuff they use for pig's
blood and carry what's matter Sydney you
look like you've seen a ghost baby seems
only if you believe he'll know these
things were made by the US Army Corps of
Engineers
[Music]
what else does Johnny tell you she says
she wants me to live here forever and
ever it's how we can all play it again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
those moments when you're not sure the
undead are really vented don't get all
stingy with your bullets
[Music]
because uh go camping
[Laughter]
cuz right there is something here
[Music]
the passage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
doesn't like to be cheated
excuse me you all just be careful
actually advice creepy guy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no one official is prepared to comment
religious groups are calling it Judgment
Day then an increasing number of reports
of literally being a witness reports and
sketchy one unifying detail seems to be
that the attackers in many instances
appear to be a Monday speaks of the
night so I looked up sin must I bet
buyer in much in Soompi case it's
[Music]
alright
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we gotta play safe no matter what
happens we have to stay together
this is right we should split up you can
cover more ground that way yeah good
idea
really
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I know this sounds crazy but I've I've
got books here look maybe all this is
coincidence but one thing is for sure
they have a coven and they weren't my
baby certainly seems that way
[Music]
[Music]
don't do your name I'll tell you mine I
don't think so
never told me na why do you want to know
my name's I want to know what I'm
looking at what did you say
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]